Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first thousand people to click the link in
the description can get a one month free
trial of Skillshare’s premium membership
so you can start exploring your creativity today.
We recently did an episode
about nematodes,
the phylum of worm that outnumbers
just about every animal on this planet.
Now, it's not the most striking of animals,
but the nematode has had a few
distinguished scientific decades,
thanks to its many uses in laboratories.
So as far as worms go,
the nematode seems to dominate
much of our scientific understanding.
But worms, despite their seemingly simple
bodies, are a diverse bunch.
Which is why we thought for today it might
be fun to visit with a less famous worm
and like one of those relatives
that you don't really know very much about
But every time you see them,
there's a new strange story to unpack
They are the Aeolosomatids,
a family of freshwater worms.
The ones that you see here are invaders.
They showed up uninvited
in a blepharisma culture that
James, our master of microscopes,
has been taken care of for a long time.
And while Aeolosoma worms are
you know, worms,
they are in a different class of worm
because as we have seen before,
there are, in fact, many ways to be a tube.
Where nematodes are roundworms,
Aeolosoma are segmented,
placing them in the Annelid phylum,
along with earthworms and leeches,
Aeolosoma are usually several millimeters in length,
their bodies divided into more
than ten segments that you can see
scrunching up and expanding as the worm
wiggles its way through the microcosmos.
And the Aeolosoma are striking to look at.
You can see their organs
through their transparent bodies,
and as it moves, bundles of long bristly
hairs wave along the side of its body.
Those hairs mark the Aeolosoma
as a specific type of an annelid
called a polychaete, or bristle worm.
Some bristle worms are found
in unusual places like hydrothermal vents,
but our Aeolosoma come
from a much more mundane home.
They're usually found in bodies
of fresh water where they'd like to crawl
among the leaves and algae
that settle at the bottom of the water.
And inside their bodies
are colorful gland cells,
though no one is really sure
what those cells exist for
or why they have their particular colors.
And some species, the cells are green
and others they're yellow.
And sometimes,
as with our worms, they're red.
The final result is a worm
that looks a little like it
ran into a porcupine
while also having caught chicken pox.
While there are some Aeolosoma
species that reproduce sexually,
most reproduce asexually dividing
to form a copy of itself.
The Aeolosoma creates its clone at its end,
linking the old and new versions of itself
like a chain.
You can see the new Aeolosoma here,
looking like it's attached to the other’s butt because,
it's attached to the other’s butt.
And this chain can keep going
as the Aeolosoma
keeps dividing, adding more worms
that are connected together
so that the final length
of their combined bodies sometimes
reaches around ten millimeters total.
That's ten millimeters of clones
combined to create one giant mega worm
until eventually the chain breaks
and they all go their separate ways.
So when James found these worms
invading his samples, you'd think
maybe this would be an exciting find.
Here is a culture full of bristled,
polka-dotted, chain-forming clones.
What could be more exciting!
Well, as wonderful as they are to
look at these invasions are not ideal
because they are also essentially vacuum cleaners.
Their mouths are lined with cilia
that wave around and help the worms
suction up bits of plant and animal debris.
When they're in a pond,
They like to crawl across leaves
and algae for their meals.
But when you find them
in bottles of ciliate cultures,
you've been lovingly maintaining,
that's when things get a bit dicier.
Because Aeolosoma will eat
just about anything, including each other.
Indeed.
in one very dramatic scene
documented in 1901 scientists
observing the species Aeolosoma tenebrarum
described the way
these chains of worms
would twist up in each other,
creating a writhing, tangled ball of worms
that would stay stuck together
for long periods of time.
And when the scientists pulled
these balls apart, they usually found
at least one worm
that had been partially eaten.
I'm sure the etiquette around
cannibalistic frenzies varies,
but for most animals, getting eaten
by another member of your species
would seem, at the very least,
a little rude.
But when you're Aeolosoma,
it's not that big of a deal.
Honestly, it's not much
more than an inconvenience,
because if a part of it gets eaten,
it can always regenerate
In one case, the scientists watching these
balls of worms found that one worm had its head eaten.
But in about three days
it was able to make a new one.
It would probably have taken less time
to regenerate other parts of their body-
heads seemed to take the Aeolosoma a bit longer,
perhaps because of all the complex parts
that need to be rebuilt.
And the Aeolosoma can regenerate even
when it is cut into multiple segments.
This superpower has made one species
called Aeolosoma viride
particularly interesting to scientists.
And it's not just
that they can regenerate.
After all, as incredible as this ability
is, there are plenty of other animals
that can regenerate as well.
But scientists aren't just interested
in how animals regenerate.
They also want to know how
those regenerative abilities
change as the animal gets older.
That's a difficult question to study
because as you might expect,
self-healing animals have often, pretty long lifespans.
So it's a challenge to wait years
or even decades to study how their ability
to regenerate changes
with the wear and tear of aging.
Aeolosoma viride
however, has a lifespan
of only about two months,
which means it goes from young to old
on a manageable timescale for scientists
cycling through experiments.
And that makes it a useful organism
to observe how that capacity
to rebuild itself changes
as the worm ages.
But as useful as regeneration
is for survival,
it is not the only tool
the worm relies on.
After all, not all dangers can easily
be patched up by rebuilding body parts.
Sometimes the worm has to preempt
dangerous conditions, and for that
it turns to the cyst.
In nature, the worms will likely begin
forming these cysts in autumn,
when the water gets cold and begins to fill
with the remains of decomposing life.
And as the temperatures continue
to fall, the worms begin to slow down,
crawling to areas full of delicious debris
for them to stock up on, and eventually,
the worms begin to secrete a mucus,
creating a gooey
shell that then hardens into a cyst.
You can see the granules of red pigment
swirling around as the worm moves inside.
Some of that activity
might be the peristaltic movement
of its intestines, but it's also possible
that the warmth of the microscope lamp
is causing the worms to stir as well.
And in their ponds,
when warm weather comes, the worm
will get ready to emerge from its encased
hibernation, using its head
to push at the hardened case of its cyst
until it manages to poke a hole through
from which it can escape.
It can take a worm anywhere
from 30 minutes
to several hours to make its exit.
And if there's a thick
coating of bacteria on the cyst,
it may even take the worms several days.
And from there well,
it is a life of suction,
feeding and chain
link clones and regenerating.
Perhaps not normal to us,
but what's normal anyway?
Especially when you're a worm.
Thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us.
We would also like to say thank you again
to Skillshare for supporting this video.
Maybe you're sitting there thinking,
I'm tired of watching
all these YouTube videos.
I want to try making some of my own.
Well, that is one of the many things
you can learn to do using Skillshare.
There you will find the course
Filmmaking For Content Creators,
where host Aaron Palabyab teaches
you how to be an efficient
and well-prepared solo filmmaker.
Whether it's for your own content
or for professional work.
His course aims to both demystify
the filmmaking process and empower you
to shoot high quality videos
all on your own.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that can help you make 2022
a year of new learning,
growth and connection through creativity.
With so much to explore
and real world projects to create,
Skillshare empowers
you to accomplish real growth.
It's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they're always
launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused
on leveling up your skills.
And if you're one of the first thousand
people to click on the link
in the description,
you can get a one month free
trial of Skillshare’s premium membership.
There are a bunch of names on your screen
right now, and those names are tied to people,
and those people are individuals
who each made an individual decision
that they would like this content
to exist on the Internet.
And if you feel like this
content should exist on the Internet,
maybe you would like your name to be here.
And that can happen if you become
a Patreon patron at
Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro
If you want to see more
from our Master of Microscopes,
James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.